you know there is another huge event
before we get to the Oscars and Cameron
Superbowl 50 that's not yet countdown is
underway man I am psyched Kevin Frazier
is at Super Bowl party central without
special correspondent actress Cassidy
Gifford daughter of Kathie Lee and Frank
Gifford Cassidy welcome to are you two
team thanks Cameron I can't tell you how
excited I am to be here in San Francisco
with Kevin we are having a blast Cameron
and welcome to our home away from home
the visa Everywhere lounge now here's
the thing about Cassidy she really is a
Super Bowl veteran because her father of
course one of the greatest players in
the history of the NFL and a Hall of
Fame broadcaster
but her mom sang the national anthem in
1995 at the Super Bowl do you remember
that well that is true but no I don't
remember it Kevin could seeing as I was
2 years old
in 1995 wonderful that is special and so
is the fact that her dad broadcast the
very first Super Bowl so it was really a
full-circle moment when Cassidy got to
sit down with the guys from CBS who are
broadcasting Super Bowl 50
dad was a great man I love him saw him
all the time but you don't look like him
thank you all right okay Phil like Frank
transitioned from the field to the
broadcast booth when he would prepare
back in the day you know be so different
he would say it was something like kind
of preparing for an exam when he would
try to equate it for me for you how is
it I think that's a little bit of it I
love the fact that you note preparing
and making sure I know everything I can
about the players as far as their what
they do on the tonight CBS analyst Tony
Gonzalez and Boomer Esiason also
followed Frank's career path this great
league that we have been a part of for
many many years was built on the back of
people like your dad the last couple
years of my dad's life I remember
sitting and watching with him and he's
like I'm just so happy that those guys
are up there now he's like they are
doing so much better than I could have
done this game as everybody talking
about the matchup between 39 year-old
Peyton Manning of the Broncos and 26
year-old Cam Newton of the Panthers
Peyton Manning's Frank Sinatra yeah
Cam Newton is jay-z yes you know like
two totally different styles I actually
have a pair pants similar to that oh
yeah he borrowed them from me and
Cassidy got the CBS Sports Chairman to
break some news and he announced today
that we are renewing Thursday Night
Football on CBS people may not know that
Shaun's father was legendary ABC
broadcaster Jim McKay who worked with
Frank Gifford for decades it's ironic
that his offspring and Frank's offspring
get to sit here and do an interview so
there's something very serendipitous
about absolutely no it's very exciting
great stuff um how was that for you it
was pretty surreal Kevin honestly to
talk to these guys and sit down who my
dad have nothing but the utmost respect
for and it was pretty surreal yeah that
is great speaking of surreal oh we are
headed to NFL media day and there is
nothing crazier than media day at the
Super Bowl are you ready for this no I
keep hearing it's pretty crazy
oh I hope your mom forgives us and by
the way I want to remind everybody out
there starting tonight you can check out
et at the big game on pump it's our
Super Bowl special check your local
listings all right
Cassady let's go to the cameraman it's
either back to you Oh
good luck is Oh - thank you very much
Kevin and Cassidy me media day it's a
madhouse